welcome to the refurbished rangiora town
hall on the corner of high and king
streets
the town hall is the venue of choice for
stage productions musical events and
theater
the improved auditorium facilities
include a large scenery dock with easy
access for trucks to unload sets props
sound gear musical instruments costumes
and equipment
a mobile lift makes unpacking and
transporting light work
full height stage doors allow
unrestricted access for sets and props
the stage includes a fly tower for
lifting and lowering sets and holding
extensive lighting
the sound control room is at the back of
the 360 seat auditorium
beneath the stage the orchestra pit
comfortably seats 20 musicians and their
instruments adjacent to the orchestra
pit on the lower level is a musician's
assembly area for unpacking instruments
and a musician's room all accessed by
stairs and a lift
directly across the wide back corridor
from the stage door are the dressing
rooms both are spacious and air
conditioned with ample bench space
lighting and hand basin and include a
live feed from the stage
also accessed from the corridor are
toilets and showers and a kitchenette
with a fridge
the corridor provides storage for the
grand piano which is available for hire
this corridor connects with the scenery
dock and the stage door for cast and
crew
the new 150 seat theater features
retractable seating and an expandable
stage
the theater has wide stage access ideal
for drama dance and musical performances
and includes an extensive sky deck for
rigging lights
backstage are two dressing rooms and
toilets for cast and crew
these facilities can also be used in
conjunction with performances in the
auditorium which involve a larger cast
on the first floor are four soundproofed
studio rooms ideal for musicians and
actors to rehearse
an adjacent green room provides an
informal relaxing space with kitchen
facilities including a fridge and
microwave oven
the auditorium theatre studio rooms and
green rooms can all be hired
individually all together the rangiora
town hall is the perfect venue for
staged productions and events
you